- And did you love, like,
playing your character?
You felt personally kinda connected
to being able to do this, right?
- I felt hugely connected.
I felt hugely connected
because the breakdown of the
character in the audition
is, she's maternal,
and she brings some joy
and, you know-
- [Kelly] And you sing.
- And I sing.
- Yeah, you do.
- Yeah, so for me
it just felt like a really iconic moment.
She is the first female dwarf
to have ever truly been seen
within the world of
Tolkein or this franchise.
She is the first dwarf of color
to have ever been seen
within this franchise.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
And so it felt like a moment to rise
and I was very, very pregnant
at the time of auditioning,
and so, yeah, it's been a whole-
- My God, I hated working
when I was pregnant.
- Two days away from giving
birth before audition.
- What?
- Baby engaged,
midwives on speed-dial.
- The diaphragm has left.
- I'm doing the camera test like this.
(laughing)
- I mean, what about
costumes, was that an issue?
- Costumes?
Can I just say the
first conversation I had
with the design team, she said,
"You're breastfeeding, right?"
"What do you need?"
- First of all, I love
that someone just said,
"So you're breastfeeding"
(audience clapping)
- Yeah
- But that's so helpful
'cause people don't think about that.
- So if there's pictures on my costume
but there's like these
stitching on, on the shoulders
and that was literally
in between takes me going
so what is it, what are we saying?
(all laughing)
(clapping)
- I love that that's
kind of your character
in the film too, though.
- Yeah.
- She's kinda like very
nurturing and funny
and it just, it's a
really great character.
- I appreciate it, thank you.
- I love y'all's relationship.
It's so cool.